weg frei für den exit das britische
unterhaus stimmt für das von premier
johnson ausgehandelte austritts abkommen
mit der eu
ärger um diensthandy die telefondaten
der damaligen verteidigungsministerin
von der leyen wurden gelöscht obwohl sie
in der berater affäre als beweismittel
dienen sollten
und erfolg im nebel von gröden
skirennläufer thomas dreesen rast im
super g auf den dritten rang
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
rudi cerne ist auch dabei für den sport
hallo guten amt der britische premier
boris johnson spricht von einem
wendepunkt in der nationalen geschichte
nach dreieinhalb jahren gerangel um den
break cit hat das unterhaus heute seinem
scheidungsvertrag mit der eu und damit
dem exit zum 31 januar zugestimmt
möglich gemacht hat das johnsons
deutlicher wahlsieg vor einer woche der
ihm eine satte mehrheit im parlament
verschafft hat aus london michael
haselrieder bei der fahrt zum parlament
dürfte der britische premier diesmal
ganz entspannt gewesen sein
oft waren dragset abstimmungen in der
vergangenheit schiefgegangen doch seit
der wahl hat boris johnson eine satte
mehrheit die heute seinem gesetz
zustimmt dafür habe gestimmt 358 dagegen
haben gestimmt 234
boris johnson ist damit seinem ziel
einen großen schritt näher gekommen
jetzt ist der moment gekommen wo wir die
eu verlassen und unser land wieder
vereinen um ein neues spannendes kapitel
in unserer geschichte zu schreiben
wir schmücken ein neues bündnis mit
unseren europäischen freunden um ein
großes land zu bleiben der
heilungsprozess in diesem land kann
beginnen
doch davon war heute im parlament nicht
viel zu spüren der black city werde der
wirtschaft schaden fürchtet die labour
opposition
je mehr die regierung von den bisherigen
eu handelsregeln abweicht desto mehr
kontrollen und störungen wird es
zwischen uns und unserem größten
handelspartner geben
die opposition kritisiert außerdem dass
johnson eine verlängerung der
übergangszeit nach dem wechsel per
gesetz ausgeschlossen hat damit bleiben
für die verhandlungen mit der eu über
ein handelsabkommen nur wenige monate
zeit bei den verhandlungen will bosch
sonsten sich in zukunft nicht mehr so
viel vom parlament hineinreden lassen
die mitspracherechte die sich das
parlament in der vergangenheit erkämpft
hat hat er weitgehend wieder abgeschafft
die unendliche geschichte vom brett sie
hat auch heute noch kein ende gefunden
nach deutschland ein handy sorgt für
mächtig ärger in berlin genauer gesagt
ein diensthandy von ursula von der leyen
aus ihrer zeit als
verteidigungsministerin der
untersuchungsausschuss zur berater
affäre hatte daten davon angefordert
jetzt kam raus die handydaten wurden
komplett gelöscht
aus sicherheitsgründen sagt das
verteidigungsministerium
oppositionspolitiker nennen das
vernichtung von beweismitteln cornelia
schiemenz berichtet das ehemalige handy
der ehemaligen verteidigungsministerin
sorgt in berlin für aufregung hat ursula
von der leyen per sms per mail
möglicherweise anweisungen erteilt die
für die aufklärung der berater affäre
von relevanz wären ihr ehemaliges
ministerium macht widersprüchliche
angaben
erst hieß ist das handy sei weg dann war
angeblich die pin unbekannt nun sind die
daten gelöscht
vor einiger zeit ein stopp im sommer
diesen jahres war es dass verschiedene
nummern von politikern die
öffentlichkeit geraten sind darunter war
auch ihre dienst handynummer daraufhin
wusste sie ihr handy zurückgeben und die
regularien sind dass diese handys dann
sicherheits gelöscht werden
seit februar gibt es einen
untersuchungsausschuss zur berater
affäre das verteidigungsministerium soll
jahrelang millionenschwere aufträge ohne
ausschreibung vergeben haben
mit der vernichtung des diensthandys der
ministerin a d fällt ein wichtiges
beweismittel weg die opposition spricht
von vertuschung des bmvg erfindet bis
heute nur ausflüchte dafür warum das
handy gelöscht wurde der datenklau kann
es nicht sein
da hat im januar stattgefunden die
ministerin hat das handy ja danach
behalten
als zweithandy hat abgegeben auch
ungelöst abgegeben als er aus dem amt
ausgeschieden ist und dann hat man sich
dort bewusst entschieden es zu löschen
obwohl es nur anderweitiger anweisung
gab
ich lasse jetzt im moment prüfen ob das
sogar strafrechtlich relevant ist
von der leyens handy wurde im august
sicherheits gelöscht wenige wochen
nachdem der u-ausschuss einsicht in die
handydaten forderte an zufall mag die
opposition da nicht glauben
dreieinhalb monate nach der landtagswahl
steht in sachsen eine neue regierung
zur erinnerung hier nochmal das
wahlergebnis vom september die cdu
stärkste kraft knapp vor der afd
dahinter die linke die grünen und die
spd bündnisse mit fdp und linken hatte
ministerpräsident kretschmann
kategorisch ausgeschlossen
so blieb nur die koalition aus cdu spd
und grünen die jetzt ihre arbeit
aufnimmt aus dresden stefan kech ein
dreierbündnis gab es in sachsen noch nie
doch um weiter regieren zu können musste
die cdu spd und grüne mit an den
kabinettstisch lassen sie und ihre
themen so wird diese konstellation vor
allem eins anstrengend das ist nicht
einfach gewesen es sieht nach außen
alles immer leichter aus als es ist soll
es auch aber es ist uns gelungen eine
gute regierung auf die beine zu stellen
die wird nun allerdings hauptsächlich
von kompromissen getragen und sie ist
zum erfolg verdammt
die regierung kretschmann muss beweisen
dass dieses zweckbündnis mehr ist als
eine anti af.de koalition
wir haben gezeigt dass auch
unterschiedliche partner in der lage
sind gemeinsam einen guten plan für die
zukunft zu entwickeln den wir jetzt wird
kraft auch umsetzen will
zeit und finanzdruck werden den
ehrgeizigen vorhaben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag grenzen setzen
themen wie versorgung des ländlichen
raumes der aufbau digitaler
infrastruktur oder der kohleausstieg
haben grosses streitpotenzial der
erstarkten afd ist es mehr als recht ist
im koalitionsvertrag eine grüne zum teil
sozialistische handschrift wir werden
der konservative block im sächsischen
parlament sein und wir werden daran
arbeiten dass diese koalition
hoffentlich keine fünf jahre hält und
dass sachsen dieses experimente nicht
fünf jahre lang ertragen muss die wahl
des ministerpräsidenten zeigt dass es
auch innerhalb der regierungsparteien
und zufriedenheit mit den kompromissen
gibt nicht alle koalitionäre geben heute
ihre stimme michael kretschmer von
sachsen nach sachsen anhalt die kontakte
des cdu kommunalpolitikers robert möritz
zur rechtsextremen szene haben die
dortige schwarz rot grüne koalition
schwer belastet jetzt ist wird aus der
cdu ausgetreten
der 29 jährige hatte eingeräumt dass er
2011 als ordner an einer neonazi demo
teilgenommen hatte und ein einschlägiges
tattoo trägt gestern hatte ihm die
landes cdu ein ultimatum gestellt sich
zu distanzieren und lückenlos
aufzuklären
alle drei jahre lebt der zentralrat der
juden in deutschland die mitglieder der
gemeinde zur größten jüdischen
veranstaltung hierzulande dem
gemeindetag bei der eröffnung gestern
abend rief bundespräsident steinmeier
eindringlich dazu auf sich dem
ausbreitenden antisemitismus
entgegenzustellen
was da mittlerweile zum alltag von juden
in deutschland gehört zeigt ruhe
leskovar irgendwie jüdisch unter dem
titel blog jona grossmann regelmäßig
schreibt kolumnen über ihr jüdisches
leben in deutschland seitdem kämpft sie
mit anfeindungen antisemitische
beleidigungen bilder wie diese geld das
in den gasofen führt es sind dann eben
sachen wie der zug nach auschwitz wartet
schon und die man sehr wohl versteht
oder wenn du aus dem haus gehe ist guck
mal lieber wo du hingehst oder werde
erfolg das könnte ganz schnell gehen das
problem antisemitismus eines der
zentralen themen auf dem jüdischen
gemeinde tag der anschlag auf die
synagoge in halle hat das
sicherheitsgefühl vieler juden
nachhaltig erschüttert die anzahl
antisemitischer straftaten steigt seit
einigen jahren wieder 2018 waren es 1799
für den präsidenten des zentralrats ist
der antisemitismus salon väter geworden
heute getraut man sich zu sagen was man
lange zeit gedacht hat sich nicht
getraut hat zu sagen und dadurch werden
und wurden rote linien eindeutig
verschoben
der bundespräsident eröffnete den
gemeindetag mahnte die wachsende gefahr
ernst zu nehmen
antisemitismus offen zu widersprechen
wenn wir schweigen wenn wir nicht
verhindern dass die atmosphäre in
unserem land weiter vergiftet wird kann
jeder und jede das nächste ziel werden
das lehrt uns die geschichte yu-na
grossmann hätte sich auch mehr
widerspruch gegen die anfeindungen
gewünscht solidarität sollte alltäglich
gezeigt werden nicht nur auf dem
jüdischen gemeinde tag
und es lohnt sich noch mal in die
ansprache des bundespräsidenten
reinzuschauen auf heute de können sie
das tun da ist die rede in voller länge
zu sehen
lange wurde ums klima paket der
koalition gestritten auch die länder
waren unzufrieden
der bund musste nachbessern den preis
pro tonne co2 deutlich erhöhen
jetzt hat der bundesrat zugestimmt also
bahnfahren wird günstiger heizen mit öl
oder gas teurer
autofahren auch es gibt aber
erleichterungen für fernpendler was das
im einzelnen für die bürger bedeutet
zeigt david sauer
als erste werden bahnkunden das
klimaschutzprogramm spüren als
entlastung ab dem neuen jahr fällt bei
bahntickets die mehrwertsteuer von 19
auf 7 prozent ab januar 2021 kostet
privater co2 ausstoß geld kohle und gas
werden teurer und auch heizöl bei einem
haus von 120 quadratmetern bedeutet dass
etwa 140 euro mehrkosten im jahr
experten empfehlen dichtungen an
fenstern und türen zu prüfen
wirklich helfen aber nur eine neue
dämmung oder eine neue heizung das geht
richtig ins geld zurück 70 80.000 euro
los bei so eine immobilie
da muss man sich überlegen kann man das
überhaupt finanzieren
immerhin dafür gibt es bis zu 20 prozent
staatliche förderung beim strompreis
werden bürger ab 2021 entlastet die eeg
umlage mit der verbraucher den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien mit finanzieren
wird pro kilowattstunde um 1,75 cent
gesenkt macht für einen vier personen
haushalt im schnitt 60 euro ersparnis im
jahr 2025 noch mal mehr so ist
jedenfalls der plan
unsere große befürchtung ist dass die
stromkonzerne einen teil der eeg umlagen
senkung für sich abgreifen ihre gewinne
erhöhen
darum heute die ganz klare botschaft das
darf nicht passieren
auch für autofahrer hat das
klimaschutzprogramm direkte folgen 2021
werden benzin und diesel um mehr als
sieben cent pro liter teurer
bis 2025 um insgesamt mehr als 14 cent
dafür wird ab dem 21
die pendlerpauschale angehoben 2021 um
15 4 kilometer
2024 um weitere drei sind und wir
schauen nach china wo derzeit groß
gefeiert wird 20 jahre sind vergangen
seitdem die frühere portugiesische
kolonie macau unabhängig wurde die
kleine schwester von hongkong sozusagen
das europäische flair ist nur zu spüren
doch längst überragend glaspaläste die
altstadt denn peking erlaubt glücksspiel
im großen stil viele milliarden
us-dollar pro jahr tragen vor allem
asiaten in die bunten casinos längst ist
der umsatz höher als in las vegas dass
ich so viel geld ganz anders politisch
auswirkt als in hongkong zeigt ulf
röller mit einer großen gala feiern sie
den geburtstag pekings machthaber lieben
macau die sonderzone die sich
geräuschlos in chinas riesenreich
eingefügt hat ganz im gegenteil zum
aufrührerischen hongkong präsident sie
hat deshalb eine warnung zur feier
mitgebracht
wir werden auf keinen fall zulassen dass
sich ausländische kräfte in die
angelegenheit von hongkong und macao
englischen macao lebt vom glücksspiel
die chinesen lieben das bizarre ambiente
einmal hier urlaub machen ein traum für
viele wenn wir urlaub machen kommen wir
gerne nach macau die luft es gut der
service auch es ist sauber die preise
sind fair
makaus rund 700.000 einwohnern geht es
gut sie sind aber abhängig vom geld der
chinesen nur noch die architektur und
die straßenschilder erinnern an die
portugiesische herkunft so viele
geschäfte hängen von den kunden aus
festlandchina ab wenn die nicht mehr
kämen leidet unsere wirtschaft und dann
verlieren viele ihren job nachts
leuchtet die spielerstadt vor allem die
chinesischen touristen machen markus
bevölkerung reich sie würde deshalb
nicht gegen china aufbegehren denn die
hand die einen füttert beißt man nicht
china hat max zukunft fest im griff
es könnte künftig ein exklusives
weihnachtsgeschenk werden ein flug ins
all mit dem raumfrachter starliner der
us flugzeugbauer boeing schickte ihn
heute mit hilfe der trägerrakete atlas 5
auf einen testflug das ziel die
raumstation iss
so sieht der starliner in originalgröße
aus erinnert an die apollo kapsel von
1969 ist aber ein modernes
hightech-produkt die konstruktion ganz
ohne nähte soll besonders robust und oft
wieder verwendbar sein um sicher zurück
zur erde zu kommen gibt es fallschirme
und airbags an der unterseite zu sehen
bei tests in der wüste von nevada sieben
personen sollen hier reinpassen
heute sei es allerdings erst mal nur
eine puppe im starliner vielleicht gar
nicht schlecht
der start perfekt doch der starliner
erreichte am ende nicht die richtige
umlaufbahn
ein andocken an die iss damit unmöglich
bleibt boeing und der nasa nur noch eine
kontrollierte rückkehr zur erde
dabei war eigentlich geplant dass das
raumschiff schon 2021 menschen zur iss
bringt der wird jetzt so ein bisschen
länger dauern ruder und beim fußball
genau kurz vor weihnachten müssen die
bundesliga fußballer noch mal ran der
siebzehnte spieltag wird heute abend mit
der partie hoffenheim gegen borussia
dortmund eröffnet zu sehen bei uns im
zdf katrin müller hohenstein in sinsheim
wie groß sind die verletzungssorgen beim
bvb der kapitän fehlt und hinter dem
zuletzt erfolgreichsten torschützen
stand auch ein fragezeichen
ja das ist richtig ruhig marco reus wird
definitiv nicht spielen
wer es nämlich auch gar nicht dabei ein
muskelfaserriss zwingt ihn zur pause
aber rieben sancho ist dabei es auch im
kader der torgarant des bvb in den
letzten wochen in den letzten sieben
pflichtspielen hat er immer getroffen
am dienstagabend im spiel gegen leipzig
musste er vom platz mit muskelkrämpfen
also mal sehen aber heute abend spielen
kann und wird und wenn ja wie lange es
ist das letzte hinrunden spiel für beide
mannschaften es geht darum hier drei
punkte zu holen um sich vorab und die
mannschaft und die fans mit drei punkten
zu weihnachten zu beschenken und so
freuen wir uns jetzt schon auf einen
wirklich schönen fußballabend wir melden
uns mit der partie hoffenheim gegen den
bvb ab 20 15 live im zdf
danke katrin und bis nachher
skirennläufer thomas dreesen kann in
seiner comeback saison erneut einen
erfolg bejubeln drei wochen nach seinem
überraschenden abfahrtssieg in lake
louise fuhr der 26-jährige beim super g
in gröden auf den dritten rang
eine beherzte fahrt von thomas dreesen
in einem äußerst zähen superjet happy
end
wegen des starken nebels in den
dolomiten muss das rennen mehrfach
unterbrochen werden und steht kurz vor
dem abbruch
thomas dreesen davon unbeirrt ebenso wie
von einem leicht geschwollenen knie
platz 3 der deutsche fährt zum zweiten
mal in dieser saison aufs podest
ich habe ja selber und dann vorne
gewusst wie schnee dass ich bin war
natürlich geil wo eben ziel den drei
jahre auf leicht gesenkt habe ihr mann
einfach darf der campus des ist also
matschie der kennt man ihn den sieg
sicherte sich der österreicher vincent
kriechmayr forscher jansrud aus norwegen
zweitbester deutscher andreas sander auf
platz zwölf formverbessert nach zuletzt
enttäuschenden resultaten biathletin
denise herrmann mit platz fünf im sprint
von lego roboter in frankreich zwei
fehler beim stehendschießen kosteten sie
einen möglichen podiumsplatz beim sieg
der norwegerinnen tiere leck auf damit
hat sich hermann eine gute
ausgangsposition für das
verfolgungsrennen verschafft dass sie im
übrigen morgen im zdf im rahmen der
wintersport sendung sehen können das
wars vielen dank
zum schluss noch der blick auf eine
wirklich schöne tradition von
entertainer frank zander
seit 25 jahren lebt er obdachlose zum
weihnachtlichen gänseessen 1 3000
berliner bedürftige bedient werden sie
von hunderten von helfern darunter
etliche politiker und prominente es sei
eine familienfeier die ein bisschen
größer geworden ist sagt zander
zur begrüßung wird übrigens jeder gast
umarmt wenig herz erwärmen dagegen das
wetter in der nacht regnet es noch
kräftig wann es morgen trockener wird
sagt ihnen gleich aus dem verlies das
heute journal mit marietta slomka in der
halbzeitpause um viertel nach neun
machen sie sich noch einen schönen
freitagabend danke für ihr interesse und
bis machen wenn sie müssen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter als ziemlich
heftiges tiefe erreicht den westen
europas hier zum beispiel frankreich und
spanien
und dieses sturm fällt teils mit
orkanböen zieht auch weiter richtung
mittelmeer oder erreicht auch den süden
italiens also da ist einiges los kein
vergleich zu deutschland hier frist zwar
der wind auch auf aber nicht so heftig
schauen wir mal in die nacht da gibt es
regen im osten deutschlands und auch im
südosten das zieht weiter langsam
ostwärts im westen klart es schon wieder
auf temperaturmäßig liegen wir zwischen
2 grad am alpenrand und 7 grad an der
nordsee
es ist insgesamt eine frostfreie nacht
morgen lässt der regen im osten nach und
auch im südosten ganz im westen richtung
saarland zum beispiel gibt es einige
tropfen das ist aber nicht viel sonst
zeigt sich die sonne in der mitte und im
süden bei temperaturen zwischen sechs
grad im vogtland und elf grad am
oberrhein
die nächsten tage werden allmählich
durchwachsener sonntag kommt regen auf
es wird im süden windiger fünf bis zehn
grad gunter montag und heilig abend dann
noch windiger teils mit schnee in den
mittelgebirgen damit wünsche ich ihnen
einen schönen abend